welcome to this video playing psycho
cowboy isle of man yeah the Sun Williams
is probably still on the Isle of Man
after yes plate think yes plates not
doing any other work on it on this some
this big tournament though obviously I
wanted to play we should be too ok
Bishop d3 is not bad but I have no idea
about it so ok yes plate and this some I
think this is pokerstars tournament the
Isle of men um this castle it's now on
oh I don't know yeah I think castles so
there's some way here maybe I can just
keep the center like this let's plate
the Kings Indian it's nothing that he's
doing regularly let's see if he can
manage to to win yet another game
against me yet this very funny at this
game where he was beating me this funny
pre move on we promote Rick yeah I will
keep the center I don't want to play d 5
so early black sometimes runs out of
good ideas and such a structure it would
play stuff like King age 8 and so on
let's see and it's normally a good idea
to keep things so I am so now I can play
the five
okay it's not going to e7 interesting
Lee enough yeah I won't give you my
bishop that much is clear now I have a
position of threat a three-night a6
before yeah that's good that's a good
prophylactic move um should I play a 3
mm not sure going to prepare that yep is
back-- try to play a five so let's say a
3 i'm good at it I mean a 5 is not
really that dangerous I can play a form
or i can play capture at their form
capture and f4 looks more more promising
I can play f3 it's not not bad but I
really don't don't like the idea here
that much yeah and now i can play b form
and really miss place the whole whole
Queen side I still wonder is if there's
some drawback to the whole thing or
should I play Bishop deform immediately
before I'm thinking about stuff like
Knight b6 maybe I then it looks strange
but it takes a Texas porn now i hope i
will play this prepare before yeah
that's a weird move
Knight f6 94s now we are going to know
very going to happen okay let's see how
to do that a queen here many ideas I can
also go even c5 here okay it's clear
that you will play rook g8 and stuff
well there is there is some danger to
this kind of kind of idea that sets
clear but i still can pursue my attack
am okay King age 2 runs directly into
stuff so i'm going to h 1 yeah of course
now i have c 6 now you can take okay
let's still do it it will come to this
anyway this kind of position where black
is strategically totally busted but he
has this this Hail Mary attacking
chances Bishop takes be five wins apiece
and now I'm go here and it's not clear
where he's going yeah he can do that but
I can just should I just take the thing
play b5 and play form yeah the night on
a six is a terrible piece it is actually
probably more promising to just a ticket
when I take you can also swing over to
h6 so I should probably just keep them
keep the night out of play
yes this chick i can take here play 95
yeah that sets and that's a good idea he
can I don't mind don't mind the loss of
the exchange that much as long as the
queenside is so thoroughly dominated
okay it's of course difficult i only
have one minute left check so Queen
trade as it is a direct win so I'm going
to offer that I believe at least that I
should i why should win after Queen
tread um so now queen e to simply I
guess taking the night
i can i can double a tech g2 if you move
the bishop right now and I should have I
should have done something about that
now okay I don't know where the bishop
should go but it okay one is not
possible can go here I'm take on c7 and
I can play here and maybe this is in
fact a good idea not not winning the
exchange so much but getting rid of one
attacking rook check
Queen age 4 or something ok let's try to
use the C porn
yeah I can give this check and then
check on edge form check it feels very
dangerous but I don't see a maid at the
moment queen d 8 and the threatens made
on g ade but i'm not sure if this is
decisive i made on g8 on a a on age 8
which is seven look a queen h8 meet and
this is rook is hanging here we should
give for ya probably the ship d4 Knight
is six young can you believe this trick
unbeliever unbelievably that there was
no maid but ok I had six seconds check
yeah it's not mattering I'm winning
again here every second is just just not
possible check white for phase one time
ah yeah I am again I don't have to clock
times here would be helpful I think I
need to start a new game board or
something yeah yeah a wild game it's um
it's it's the same picture against him
every time it's so like a Hail Mary
counter-attack after every piece is
misplaced on what side of the board okay
like here ok let's see in there are many
of them anyways probably I can take e 6
and Bishop b3 and why
and to resins yeah yeah okay well I went
here because he's playing without a
six-night and yeah it's blitz chess yung
I mean in a tournament game this is very
very easy win for white but in blitz
every every kind of stupid stuff might
happen 92 defense easily but ok i was i
was thinking about giving up the
exchange because i thought that with
this knight on d5 and this is terrible
thing on a6 it should be ok takes takes
root g6 yeah and around here it's it's
interesting i'm not very surprised that
stock fish is giving white a huge edge
but the question is how exactly is it
done now that he has those he has two
rooks on the on the g2 pawn I went Queen
F to wear this is not not that great
equal computer gives equal ok b5 is
supposed supposed to be good yeah this
is the kind of cold-blooded move that
the computer will suggest and i'm not
sure i'm a maybe it will even change his
opinion if it calculates a bit deeper
this kind of thing My yes definite
counterplay definite counterplay now I'm
not sure even if the computer is giving
me an edge I'm not sure let's just check
briefly what happened of course this was
already influenced by by huge time
issues yeah this was really to get rid
of one of the rooks night c7 was my
original idea capoten night g8 was
winning why exactly King takes b6 and
I'm breaking through yeah true okay
now and v6 is of course also winning now
but where exactly did I screw it up I
think yeah there must be some sort of
made either check for us is the mate ok
this is the medicines the maid and now
how exactly is it done this yeah this ok
I get the the bishop in as well I
understand the rook d8 because the five
things yeah they are not in a couple of
seconds that not really cat and this
this I found quite amazing that black
can save this for some reason even Queen
g6 is just equal yeah i saw i saw that
this is not working but i had no time on
the clock 26 yeah yeah i mean it's not
even material down you yeah very very
hard stuff with them with no time okay
thanks for watching